Do you like to climb mountains?
No, I rarely climb mountains. What about you?
I enjoy climbing mountains.
I sometimes climb mountains with my dad.
I often go fishing with my grandpa.
Do you like going fishing?
I never go fishing.
But I expect to go fishing with you sometime.
Molly the monkey likes to climb almost everything.
Molly climbs a tall tree, to the top branch of the tree.
Molly climbs on monkey bars, to the top of the monkey bars.
Molly climbs up a tall flagpole, all the way to the very top.
Molly climbs the tall tower, all the way to the top.
Molly climbs up the big ladder, the ladder to the roof.
Molly climbs high mountains, all the way to the top.
Sometimes coming down is more fun to Molly though.